yeah welcome to this video playing
deform against Ricky key from France for
once I don't need to check it flag I
mean ok probably in them so yeah yeah
let's go for Adelaide zimage variation
I'm currently writing the chapter for
this in my book some interesting Queen a
five hmm this is similar to what Aronian
lately played against a fiddler and the
candidates should be to a server youths
yeah I don't if he takes on d4 I'd like
to recapture with the sea porn so night
I want to go nighty too as well k what
is the idea here should a six on
mm yeah interesting probably with d5
wants to go d 5 e 4 D 5 5
md5 and maybe queen a 4 in some cases so
will I Quinn be one to protect it and he
will go queen a form ok up I play the
same
I need to be an active in the center
anyway you for some just the move tool
to go on d5 I probably go e5 I need to
be ready to sacrifice a pawn here anyway
it's the same ish after all ok so d5
gaining space hmm ok this is an
interesting way to play he clears the d5
square so Bishop c295 but this isn't so
so clear I also can take s6 where he
takes on d3 take on g7 hmm
how very complicated Bishop c295 mmm not
sure that I are like that
okay and so let's do this
I hope he takes it to it's not a good
move it is it is interesting I take with
check and then he's got an amazingly
strong party too ok came now night
somewhere he can take on d4 though I
actually hoped that night f4 and night
h5 stuff like that would be a would be
good but probably it isn't mmm this is
tricky
yeah he takes on deform this is so a
problem
and probably I need to retake simply who
came and now it's not easy at all
probably I need to do that now try to
get something against the king
objectively speaking I'm certainly in
trouble here
oops
not sure that 94 was such a great move
but okay I want to go look at you what
no rookie one yeah that's don't speak
quickly don't have much time
want to have the possibility to go
rookie for at some point like Bishop g5
and then we're now rookie for what's
awesome possibility and so let's do this
cannot go f5 se6 is hanging and Knight
f6 the surrogate for its it's not clear
this this position actually what what's
what's his next move he retreats the
night i go up g for winning the Queen
want to block the pawn yeah and not
night h5 cringe to mate
you to disturb him throttling Knight f6
and this opens up the F I'll check the
ship's III rook takes Queen d4 check to
the point and this is over now I think
maybe f 6m maybe f6 but okay I can just
them but take him Queen I can can go
down check okay let's uh let's take and
take the endgame
I hope I manage in 20 seconds hi morning
it's not so easy yeah this now is easy
at least from a pure HS point of view
it's easy
check-check
check
you have to pre move pre-move is your
friend only hope their heads each other
now is writing to me beeping leg up yeah
it's not like it's pre-move you [ __ ] if
you don't know what you're doing in
online chess then it's not my problem
it's pre moving all right so um yeah
very unclear game probably this was bad
for me so if you switch on the comp it's
giving a big advantage and yeah yeah I
was surprised that he did this move here
I thought we should be seven which
basically forces f3 and then he can take
d forwards check and this now okay I'm
just trying to irritate him a bit on the
on the King position but yeah this this
already is slightly tricky you can't go
95 though 95 is a good move and this
this now is it's just lost none that's
just me they're just losing this piece
and then it's a big attack on top and
here probably I have some way to to to
play form for mating attack but okay I
already was was very much download time
it wasn't in doubt though there are 23
is even simpler I wanted to be yeah
Bishop f6 is probably a major but I
didn't I didn't it couldn't calculate
this and in 30 seconds or I mean so
quick that I can actually win the game
later yeah I wasn't sure what to do here
yeah the computer just just wants to
play g3 yeah but you don't play such a
move or you don't anticipate such a move
you can do an ax in a regular time
control game it just looks too scary to
to allow that for instance but yeah this
has probably made someone yeah this is a
mate okay well I'd let let's say he
needs to retreat and now okay this is
probably not defensible yeah thanks for
watching